welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and today
we're going to do something a little bit
different as you all may have noticed
for the last few
years i've been working pretty hard to
transform myself from
skinny little steve rogers to captain
nicaragua
from andy dwyer to star-lord i've gotten
so much out of this journey i know i
look better or whatever but i feel
better physically
mentally and now i want to help other
people get those same benefits to go
from nerd to superhero and
i want to start with my friends so i
created this show
welcome to fitness origins a 12-week
reality competition series
inspired by our favorite moments from
the mcu are you surprised or confused
yeah so were eric and tommy when i
invited them to be on this show
[Laughter]
all right no you're joking right no i'm
competing this is real
all right that is a curveball i was not
expecting that that's right i'm gonna
help my fellow new rockstars hosts eric
voss and tommy bechtold
get fit if you're a fan of the channel
you already know that tommy has these
insane theories and that
eric's analysis game is on point but on
this show
you're gonna get to know these guys in a
very different light let's check it out
hi i'm eric foss i am
not at all active i you could call me
sedentary my name is thomas michael
bechtol
i would say i'm motivated too like i'm
getting up and moving around more than i
did
um i don't exercise at all you know as
i'm starting to build a family i'm
engaged now i want to be able to
uh work out with my fiance raise a
family healthy together i'm now taking
this
this next step in um our personal
journey together
i've been trying to lose weight for like
three quarters of my life
just varying degrees of success at any
given time i've never kept it off i've
always gained more back
this is a huge opportunity that appears
to have just fallen into my lap today
now we are saving eric and tommy's
before pictures for a big reveal at the
end of the season
but they did give us a little sneak peek
with these not-safe-for-work drawings
so there's that so here are new rock
stars you're used to watching our hosts
break down their favorite movies but now
their favorite movies are going to break
down our hosts
what does that mean are you talking
about the time i saw coco what we're
gonna
do is we're going to work our way
through the mcu
learn the same lessons that our heroes
were learning and we're gonna use it to
get inspiration along the way
so we're gonna start at the beginning to
the original
og iron man fast cars
loose women losing and cruising i'm
gonna be just like iron man when this is
over
so in iron man tony makes a big change
it's not about
developing arms for the military
developing arms for your bodies
but helping people and also doing
something makes you feel good
and you guys are in that same spot right
now too you've decided to change your
lives for the better
i thought it was the story of a man and
his robot best friend
that he eventually will make into a real
person who will die
20 times so i want this to be something
that not only
you guys can do pretty easily during the
pandemic and gyms are close and all that
i want people to be able to do this at
home too so i asked you guys
to prepare your box of scraps the box of
scraps
where you uh you just bring whatever
fitness stuff you have
and then i'm gonna design a workout plan
with whatever you have i want it to be
as simple and accessible for anyone
that's watching so
what do you guys have oh well philip i
feel like you're really gonna be able to
let your imagination run wild because my
box of scraps
is pretty impressive i've got um
a yoga block a patch autograph jonathan
williams
rookie premiere materials card i've got
uh
a mankind mask mankind the wrestler
uh he's familiar so far you've had one
fitness
item oh contraire my sweet angel i've
got this thing
uh i got one last thing it's a uh 12
pound weight i'm not really sure how
this would be useful
that's it that's my box of scraps that's
it you don't even have a second 12 pound
weight no
just a one a a yoga block a weight and
a a restraint eric
i got a yoga mat and that's
it okay we will be coming up with body
weight workouts
what if our body weights aren't even
all right gentlemen it is time if you
need some extra motivation this week
go re-watch iron man 1 eric you probably
have the entire movie committed to
memory but you can just play it behind
your eyelids
exterior afghanistan kumar promise yes
it is very cool if you take a picture
with me boom boom
are you guys ready to change your lives
for the better yes yeah let's do it
i'm bringing the party to you what's up
everybody
about to do my first workout here which
is pretty exciting
day one of the workouts complete i'm way
more gassed than i thought i would be
i've never done this kind of hit
training before where it's just don't
take a break just go into the next one
go to the next one
look if iron man can reinvent himself so
can i
definitely in worse shape than i thought
i was this is normally where i would be
discouraged
and give up but i'm not gonna do that
this time
day three [ __ ] 15 minutes of hell
i literally spent part of the exercise
flat on my face
yelping for sweet sweet air all right
day four
i'm exhausted i thought mountain
climbers were easier but nothing's easy
when you have to do a lot of it
this is normally about the time my diet
completely falls apart and
stop exercising and try not to do that
turn over a new leaf be a new man well
those mountain climbers man
you know who didn't have to climb any
mountains [ __ ] tony stark
good morning how are you guys doing it's
me i'm today i'm going to work you guys
out today
yeah oh all right real quick before we
get into it though how's your first week
been
pretty good well if soreness means gains
then i've made a lot of gains yeah i had
to skip a day
because you know it was one division
finale you know i worked it but i plan
to make up for it
i promise and i like any good uh disney
plush show
resolved three out of five of my
storylines leaving just
two dangling threads that we'll make up
in season two for sure don't worry
eric you got four of the five done and
tommy you got three of the five done
yeah
yeah yeah i'm just glad that you guys
honestly
even got the majority of the week
figured out
and also we'll make up for it at the
challenge i'm sorry what this whole
thing's a challenge yeah
i thought the planks were the challenge
i thought waking up was a challenge
it is a fitness competition show of
course there are challenges did you guys
think there would be challenges
if i could have to fight tommy surprise
for him yes murder you
tommy i like you as a human being but i
will put you down
so each week eric and tommy are going to
go head to head
in a movie inspired challenge but the
challenge is just one component of the
overall competition
we're also going to factor in how well
they stick to their health and fitness
plans
when it comes to decide who won the full
week the winner is gonna get their
choice of cheat meal delivered by
doordash the finished journey is super
long it
never ends so we need these little
things to look forward to along the way
and cheat meals can be a godsend when
you're having some issues with your
willpower having that saturday night
restaurant dinner is hopefully going to
help them get through the monday through
friday
kind of sometimes hellish workouts so
doordash can connect you with the
absolute
best cheat meal options in your area
right now right to your door
ordering so easy just open the freaking
doordash app choose what you want from
where you want a few minutes later it'll
show up at your door
contactless delivery so for a limited
time our audience is going to get
25 off and zero delivery fees on your
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the code
nerd fitness again that's 25 off up to a
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the door
dash app in the app store
enter that code nerdfitness do not
forget the code it's nerdfitness
25 off your first order with doordash
subject to change
terms apply all right eric and tommy
what type of cheat meals do you want
this week
if you win i'm gonna break the rules of
nature and eat an entire chicago style
deep dish pizza
don't don't judge me okay and die ironic
one of my favorite things to do is watch
sports and eat pizza and wings i have
like a thin new york pizza
with some buffalo wings it's the deep
dish versus the
uh the brick style it's chicago versus
new york hey give me a sniper piece
i can't hear you from the l train we
above the ground up in chicago
all right uh your terrible accents are
locked in but so are your orders we'll
see who wins
uh in the meantime i actually just got a
doordash delivery myself so i hope you
guys don't mind if i eat this
delicious cheeseburger well you guys uh
work out
one two three
and the time has come for our first
challenge as a reminder we're making our
way through the mcu so after iron man
comes
the incredible hulk which inspires
today's challenge in the movies final
battle you guys remember that hulk is up
against abomination they're in harlem
and they cause
way too much damage to the city around
them
so for today's challenge your goal is to
destroy your opponent's side of the city
while protecting your own whoever does
more damage to the other side when time
is up
wins this challenge is trying to
reinforce something we've been working
on all week that no matter how big and
strong you get we actually need to
minimize the damage that you're doing to
your body by focusing on flexibility and
agility so that's going to come into
play when you're having to make some
real quick agile movements to protect
your buildings or your cars
but first y'all gotta hulk out
oh how beautiful
you guys did you put foil on yours
uh-huh i'm very proud of both of you oh
don't say
no are you guys ready yeah yeah three
two one go you want somebody i know
you're
oh
yeah all right
15 seconds
five four three
[Music]
two
yeah something came out of me that's
just i blacked out
all right uh so what we basically have
over here is complete and utter
destruction
yes of this section of harlem eric did
you defend your side at all
uh i did but i saw a look in tommy's
face that i
it just told me to get out of the way
and go on offense
all right eric i think you can't be
surprised
tommy is the clear winner here let's
give it up for tommy
winner of our first fitness challenge
yes except that does not mean that he
won the week oh
because what we actually do is i'm gonna
go back and see how they did with their
workouts and their diet
all week long and both of those things
are gonna come into play and then we'll
find out
who the real winner is of our sweet
sweet door dash cheat meal pizza
all right guys week one is in the books
how do you feel i i'm done philip i
don't think i ever need to work out
again
i think i'm physically fit eric i've
watched your vlog you're watching
oh my god good job uh on your workouts
for the week tommy it seemed like you
actually
uh weren't able to do it quite as many
workouts if we were trying to go for
perfection
this wouldn't be a 12-week program uh so
for both your cheat meals you guys both
wanted pizza
eric wanted deep dish and tommy wanted
that new york style
uh so i've been vamping because we asked
our doordash delivery drivers we paid
them a little extra
if they could hit you up at exactly 2 30
which should be
[Music]
huh are there seriously outside
there you go while they find out whether
or not they won i'll let you know that i
did the math on their week and
they both did pretty good honestly eric
missed one workout
and tommy did miss two but man that
performance from tommy in the challenge
blew eric away so obviously our winner
joe how was the delivery oh
you oh there you go yes tommy b
oh baby oh no
oh my god whoa holy crap that's a whole
head of lettuce
well this is what i actually wanted this
was my secret cheat meal i double faked
it
thank you oh this is filled with
chocolate
this is the chocolate well it's good to
know that we have the budget for one
eighth of a pizza
you thought i was actually gonna let you
get an
entire pizza on your one cheat meal i
said
a whole pizza that's my cheat meal yeah
a-hole there's your pizza
well guys that's it uh tommy is our
winner of our
first week of 12 weeks there's still
a long way to go i'm really excited to
see how these guys are going to keep
growing week to week but also
pretty soon you guys are going to be
able to join us because the same workout
videos that eric and tommy are using
are eventually going to be uploaded to
the epic hero fitness youtube channel so
go over there and subscribe to that
but also i need your guys help to keep
challenging these guys so in the
comments down below just look ahead to
the mcu it's every other movie
uh it's gonna be a challenge help me
come up with them i'll be in the
comments checking out your ideas uh and
then of course as always subscribe to
new rockstars
follow me at philip molina follow ea
boss and tommy beck told
guys give it up for them give them a
round of applause at home
all right i'll see you guys next time
eric
all right i want you to watch me
all right i'll watch you but you need to
watch me because i'm gonna get to the
molten chocolate center in a couple
bites